this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
what's up guys michael here today we're
going to talk about the off-kilter
superhero show that dares to ask is it
totally chilled to do a bunch of murders
as long as it's for some greater purpose
yup hbo max's peacemaker the james gunn
tv series takes the suicide squad's most
deplorable character and makes him the
center of a ragtag gang of special
operatives who we somehow end up rooting
for by the end the show has plenty of
guns signature humor i want to take you
home and play with you with my gi joes
just don't chewbacca here's a little
known fact wookies have teeth on their
[ __ ] that's canon and over
over-the-top violence
but we think it's also asking an
interesting question specifically is it
okay to kill as long as it's in the name
of peace to be clear wisecrack is not
endorsing murder in any way shape or
form so let's explore in this wisecrack
edition on peacemaker peace love and
bullets and as always spoilers ahead but
before we dive in i want to tell you
about this week's sponsor surfsharkvpn
surfsharkvpn helps you secure your data
by using uncrackable encryption and the
most secure vpn protocols one of the
things i love most about surfshark is
that it keeps my location totally
private and that can have huge
advantages for instance i can access
streaming content that's only been
released in other countries so i can
keep up with new movies and shows even
if they haven't reached the us yet and
now that traveling is a thing again it
keeps airlines from gouging me on
inflated ticket prices based on my
location instead i can connect my secure
surfsharkvpn to other vpns in different
countries until i track down the best
deal one subscription covers all your
favorite devices like your laptop
android amazon firestick playstation and
more plus you can still use your
favorite apps too like chrome and
firefox get started by clicking the link
in the description and using the promo
code wisecrack when you do you can get
surfsharkvpn for 83 off plus three extra
months for free go to surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today and now back
to the show let's start with a quick
refresher on john cena's peacemaker the
character who made his on-screen debut
last year in guns the suicide squad has
a pretty straightforward ethos i cherish
peace with all my heart i don't care how
many men women and children i need to
kill to get it and by the end of the
film it was clear that for him fighting
for peace means murdering your own
comrades to cover up the violent secrets
of your government's dirty deeds among
other things it was clear that gunn was
using the character to comment on both
the murderous exploits of our favorite
superheroes and the logic they used to
justify their astronomical body counts
peacemaker isn't the first modern
superhero to ponder whether or not it
can be ethical to commit violence and
violate human rights in the name of the
greater good what if the world was safe
what if next time aliens roll up to the
club and they will they couldn't get
past the bouncer but to really
understand the history of good guys
doing violence we have to go all the way
back to saint augustine no not the
historic florida city where i took field
trips in high school the theologian and
church father who was credited with
inventing just war theory this is the
idea that because god gives governments
power for good reason it can be ethical
for those governments to wage war under
certain conditions and this theory has
helped many a nation justify many a war
according to this theory the criteria
for a just war includes last resort the
force can only be used after all
peaceful options have been exhausted
legitimate authority i.e a just war can
only be pursued by a government just
cause war needs to be in response to
some wrong or attack suffered
probability of success there needs to be
a rational possibility of winning right
intention the aim of war needs to be the
re-establishment of peace
proportionality the violence inflicted
needs to be proportional to violence
suffered and civilian casualties
innocent victims should never be the
target of war and soldiers should avoid
harming them now if we were to use
augustine's criteria to evaluate the
antics of peacemaker and co in the
suicide squad film it doesn't seem like
they're waging a pure and holy war for
one they violate the last resort
criterion using violence first rather
than exhausting all other options then
again you probably don't want harley
quinn engaging in diplomacy what's more
it arguably fails on the legitimate
authority front these maker's actions
don't seem to be tied to a legitimate
government authority as task force x
functions more as a sketchy black ops
squad rather than say the department of
defense and of course there's no
proportionality happening as peacemaker
seems unlimited in his violent potential
even when it comes to his co-workers i
guess this is what happens when you
don't have an hr department and
throughout the film we never get any
indication he's concerned about his
actions being anything less than just
but in the new series peacemaker seems
more doubtful about his own motives and
is openly haunted by memories of killing
rick flagg right off the bat we see
peacemaker being grilled by a janitor
about his suspicious killing tendencies
oh
peacemaker yes you're that racist
superhero you only kill minorities man
later in the series he finds himself
unable to pull the trigger when tasked
with assassinating a whole family
including their two children peacemaker
take him out even the kids
mind you these children are possessed by
alien butterflies but shooting a kid is
still a still bad it's just a bad vibe
here peacemaker struggles with some just
war criteria including civilian
casualties and having the right
intentions soon after rather than
killing the leader of the butterflies
peacemaker keeps him in a jar and feeds
him alien goo but it's much less
fashionable these days as questions of
war have now largely transitioned into
matters of national security the current
theory used in international relations
to understand how states justify
violence is called securitization or
security theory now the just war method
of evaluating the goodness of bombs and
bullets was all the rage in the first
part of the 20th century as democratic
nations were responding to large-scale
fascism and genocide but it's much less
fashionable these days as questions of
war have now largely transitioned into
matters of national security the current
theory used in international relations
to understand how states justify
violence is called securitization or
security theory now just war theory
sought to understand what responses a
government could take after they were
already under some type of attack in
contrast securitization is all about the
national security measures a state can
justify based on potential future
threats ostensibly to keep its people
safe it's like if there are reports that
another nation is developing some new
type of high-powered weapons under
securitization even if these weapons
haven't been employed yet states might
use the specter of these threats to
justify preemptive countermeasures in
this way of thinking the responses to
what might happen rather than to what
has happened like how america invaded
iraq based on speculative threat rather
than in response to an actual attack or
how the speculative threat of future
terrorism led to the passing of the
patriot act which many argue violates
individual liberties and freedoms in the
name of security for scholar mark
neoclass the logic of security lies not
in a vision of freedom and emancipation
but in a means of modeling the whole of
human society around a particular vision
of order under the traditional just war
model violence was only necessary to
protect a state from attack but under
securitization states can arguably use
perceived threats to create systems of
order this can lead to citizens being
forced to surrender themselves to the
will of the state under the guise of
protection and security measures like
these can make the line between right
and wrong
a little murky and this seems to be at
the heart of peacemaker's original ethos
as a number of militaristic sins can be
forgiven under the guise of security i.e
preventing potential threats which
becomes another way of saying
peace including things like murdering
civilians who just happened to be in the
wrong place at the wrong time but for
mark neoclass often the security offered
is just a way to conveniently suspend
the law the idea that the permanent
emergency involves the suspension of the
law encourages the idea that resistance
must involve a return to legality a
return to the normal mode of governing
through the rule of law this involves a
serious misjudgment in which it is
simply assumed that legal procedures
both international and domestic are
designed to protect human rights from
state violence according to mark
neoclass the effect of securitization is
often creating a type of permanent
emergency that suspends the law
momentarily with the promise that this
temporary suspension will help us get
back to the normal mode of governing
through the rule of law but according to
his critique this involves a serious
misjudgment in which we assume that the
law is designed to protect our rights
and freedoms in the first place rather
than simply to give the state more power
the idea here is that if the end goal is
a return to normal and in particular a
peaceful normal then violence can be
easily justified and this logic seems to
be one that peacemaker and other members
of his team are wrestling with
throughout the series we see this logic
of securitization in the suicide squad
when the team is initially under the
impression that their mission is for the
sake of taking down some bad guys and
one giant alien monster who could
potentially kill a bunch of people
but it's later revealed that they are
simply covering the tracks of the us
government who are behind the whole
thing to begin with child
your government didn't send you here to
protect the world from alien technology
your government sent you here to cover
up their part in it and while this
reveal eventually turns most of the team
against the government for the sake of
protecting human life peacemaker doubles
down as for him protecting american
secrets and preserving peace are one and
the same and the series has a similar
vibe early on as the team's mission is
motivated by the same logic of security
even when they're largely left in the
dark about why they are actually taking
out the butterflies which again are
alien butterflies that embed themselves
in human brains to control their bodies
but the simple logic remains these
butterflies are a speculative threat to
national security and must be taken out
at all cost even if that means some
collateral kills along the way of course
this gets complicated as the team learns
more about who they are actually
fighting they eventually learn that the
butterflies are also motivated by the
logic of securitization the only
difference is that there is skews more
towards environmentalism than militarism
or nationalism and this type of
climate-based securitization is
increasingly becoming a real thing in
places like the eu after losing their
home planet to a gradually destroyed
ecosystem the butterflies are attempting
to help humans avoid the same fate by
covertly taking over the political
system to prioritize climate protection
efforts the people of earth were on the
exact same trajectory as our people had
been
ignoring science in favor of populist
leaders who tell you that the floods and
the fires and the disease are unrelated
to your own actions however in order to
do this they need to take over the
bodies of otherwise innocent human
beings effectively killing them in the
process the butterflies then beg the
same question that peacemaker's actions
do can you justify killing people in
order to preserve the peace and greater
good but peacemaker and co appear to be
motivated to stop the butterflies based
on the intel that the butterflies are
attempting to take over the planet and
must be stopped at all costs to protect
humanity and here the government is
using a threat to justify extreme
security measures ironically of course
that threat is an attempt to save the
earth from environmental catastrophe we
made a vow to make the choices for you
that you are incapable of making on your
own to save your people and your world
now the peacemaker of the suicide squad
would seemingly have no problem with
eradicating the butterflies out of a
militant commitment to the ideals of the
security state this version of the
character is just a raw embodiment of
that logic at its most extreme it seems
that with this version of the character
gunn is exploring the dark side of
america's id he even goes so far as to
make peacemaker's dad a literal nazi oh
hell
the white dragon but don't worry
peacemaker kills him
make of that what you will so does
peacemaker offer any type of solution
for the problems inherent in modern
securitization in one sense the show and
its titular character pretty explicitly
question and criticize the type of
security measures used by contemporary
western nations whether it's adebayo
struggling to understand how it's
necessary to casually kill innocent
bystanders or peacemaker being unable to
take out children as part of a mission
the team is openly grappling with their
loyalty to the security state but by the
end of the season the show has taken an
almost fatalistic approach to the idea
of morally justified violence the whole
team has become disillusioned by amanda
waller and task force x with adebayo
going so far as to snitch on her own
mother on tv it's been running for years
out of belle reef prison
under the command of
of a woman named amanda wallace
seemingly a critique of securitization
the show also seems to cast some doubt
on the morality of the good type of
securitization endorsed by the
butterflies in which rights can be
curtailed and violence can be imposed
for the sake of saving the planet and
thus humanity as a whole ultimately
peacemaker stops the remaining
butterflies from carrying out their plan
activate human torpedo
not out of disagreement with their
ideological position one he seems to
agree with and later regrets interfering
with did i just
kill the world rather he does so simply
because enabling them
might have led to his friends being
killed why did you choose not to help
them because i knew they'd hurt you and
the others if i did and now that he's
killed his nazi dad and he's seemingly
moved beyond his old commitment to
american security seems like friendship
is all he has left to believe in at the
end of the day the show seems to be
saying the logic of securitization is so
rampant that we're probably screwed
either way so in the meantime maybe look
out for your friends take the time to
rock out on long drives and try to avoid
being a literal nazi and in doing so the
show is also pretty transgressive in the
context of recent dc eu and mcu content
it's forcing us to ask if maybe some of
our heroes are actually the bad guys and
if the logic used to justify their
actions is eerily similar to the
political logic of our own societies but
what do you guys think is peacemaker a
hilarious and violent critique of
securitization or are we just trying to
justify rooting for such an odious
character let us know what you think in
the comments thanks to all of our
amazing patrons and don't forget to
check out our podcast hit that subscribe
button like you're a peacemaker helmet
in human torpedo mode and don't forget
to ring that bell and as always thanks
for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you